This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every four years, dozens of football teams from around the world, that's the soccer kind of football for our American listeners, gather for a time-honored tradition, the World Cup. And every four years, millions of football fans from around the world gather for another time-honored tradition, being mad at the World Cup.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每四年，来自世界各地的几十支足球队——对于我们的美国听众，这是指那种“足球”（soccer）——都会聚集在一起，参加一项历史悠久的传统赛事：世界杯。每四年，来自世界各地的数百万球迷也会聚集在一起，参加另一项历史悠久的传统：对世界杯感到愤怒。
Partly, they're mad at the opposing teams. That's the fun kind of mad. But they're also mad at FIFA, the nakedly corrupt organization that runs the tournament. This year, the main reason to be mad at FIFA is for outrageous price gouching. Their new dynamic ticketing system, along with their blatantly self-dealing resale market, are causing ticket prices to skyrocket. The most expensive seats for the previous World Cup final were $1,600. When the first round of tickets for this year's final went on sale,
在某种程度上，他们是对对手球队感到愤怒。那是种有趣的愤怒。但他们也对国际足联（FIFA）感到愤怒，这个组织赤裸裸地腐败，却掌控着这项赛事。今年，对国际足联感到愤怒的主要原因是其令人发指的哄抬物价行为。他们新的动态票务系统，连同其公然进行利益输送的转售市场，导致票价飞涨。上一届世界杯决赛最贵的门票是1600美元。当今年决赛的第一轮门票开始发售时，
the cheapest seats in the house started at a staggering. $2,790. Then, they more than doubled in later rounds. For those who missed the pre-sales, there's always FIFA's resale market, where they take a hefty 15% cut from both buyers and sellers. Seats behind the goal for that final game were recently listed there for $2.3 million each. Last year also saw FIFA award a sycophantic peace prize to the sitting U.S. president. The lead-up to the 2022 tournament in Qatar had numerous human.
最便宜的门票起价就高达2790美元。随后，在后续轮次中，价格翻了一倍多。对于那些错过预售的人来说，还有国际足联的转售市场，他们会从买家和卖家那里各抽取高达15%的佣金。最近，决赛中球门后方的座位在那里被标价为每张230万美元。去年，国际足联还向在任的美国总统颁发了一个谄媚的和平奖。2022年卡塔尔世界杯的筹备过程中，在体育场建设方面存在大量人权问题，据报道导致了数百名外籍劳工死亡。在此之前的一届世界杯是由俄罗斯主办的，当时正值他们吞并克里米亚之后。2015年，11名国际足联官员因收受超过1.5亿美元的贿赂而被起诉。所以我们想带大家回到2010年一场相对古怪的世界杯争议中。那些吵得要命的塑料喇叭。敬请收听。2004年春天，记者马克·格里森坐在瑞士一个小会议室的前排，等待着一个重大公告。现场气氛紧张，铺垫极具戏剧性。每个人都如坐针毡。主办2010年国际足联世界杯的获胜申办方即将揭晓，南非是主要竞争者之一。
rights violations in the construction of the stadiums, reportedly leading to the deaths of hundreds of migrant workers. The Cup before that was hosted by Russia in the wake of their annexation of Crimea. And in 2015, 11 FIFA officials were indicted for accepting over $150 million in bribes. So we thought we'd take you back to a comparatively quaint World Cup controversy from 2010. Plastic horns that were just too dang loud. Enjoy. In the spring of 2004, Journalist Mark Gleason sat in the front row of a small conference room in Switzerland for a big announcement. There was a dramatic buildup. There was a lot of tension. Everyone was on edge. The winning bid to host the 2010 FIFA World Cup was about to be revealed, and South Africa was among the leading contenders.
我的意思是，他们派出了所有重量级人物前往苏黎世参加那次公告。曼德拉去了。图图大主教去了。克拉克前总统也去了。南非希望成为第一个主办世界杯的非洲国家。他们也希望这届赛事能成为开启新篇章的起点。在种族隔离时期，该国被国际体育界禁赛。现在，他们正处于主办这项全球最大体育赛事的边缘。南非人聚集在约翰内斯堡、开普敦和德班的街头，等待国际足联的决定。我和你们一起揭晓。2010年国际足联世界杯将在南非举办。你知道，南非，它
I mean, they had all the top guns go to Zurich for that particular announcement. Mandela was there. Bishop Tutu was there. The former president of the Clack was there. South Africa wanted to be the first African nation to host the World War. World Cup. They also wanted the tournament to be the start of a new chapter. During apartheid, the country was banned from the international sporting community. Now they were on the precipice of hosting soccer's biggest event. South Africans gathered in the streets of Johannesburg, Cape Town and Durban to await FIFA's decision. I discover it with you. The 2010 FIFA World Cup will be organized in South Africa. You know, South Africa, it's
在某种意义上已经走出了可怕的过去，从一个被排斥的国家转变为现在主办世界最大体育赛事，并真正成为国际大家庭的一员。那天在苏黎世爆发的庆祝活动充满了欢呼声和哨声，但也伴随着一种后来定义了南非世界杯的臭名昭著的声音。呜呜祖拉（Vuvuzela）的声音。回到2004年，没人真正谈论呜呜祖拉。即使是足球界的人也不知道那是什么。记者詹姆斯·帕金森。
come full circle in the sense of its horrible past and how it had moved on from being a pariah state and was now, you know, hosting the biggest event in world sport and very much part of the international family. The celebrations that erupted that day in Zurich were full of cheers and whistles, but also one notorious sound that came to define South Africa's World Cup. The sound of the Vuvuzella. Back in 2004, nobody really talked about. vivisela's. Even people in the soccer world didn't know what they were. Reporter James Parkinson.
但六年后的今天，当锦标赛的第一场比赛开始时，呜呜祖拉成了体育界最热门的词汇。2010年国际足联世界杯准备开球了。伴随着8万支呜呜祖拉的声音，南非国家队（Bafana Bafana）。呜呜祖拉是一种两英尺长的注塑塑料喇叭。它只能吹出一个音符，一种单调的嗡嗡声。它逐渐成为南非足球的常规特色。
But six years later, by the time the first game of the tournament was underway, the Vuvazella was the hottest word in sports. The 2010 FIFA World Cup is ready for kickoff. And to the sound of 80,000 Vuvuzellas, Bufana Bafada. The Vuvuzela is a two-foot-long injection molded plastic horn. It plays only one note, a beef flas. And it gradually became a regular feature of South African soccer.
但在2010年世界杯之前，世界其他地方从未听过类似的声音。很多人讨厌它。它被比作一群愤怒的大黄蜂或一群心烦意乱的大象。体育场里全是呜呜祖拉的声音，太吵了。这太荒谬了。这并不吵。它没什么令人恼火的。没什么令人恼火的。但最终，对于在国外观看比赛的球迷来说，
But prior to the 2010 World Cup, the rest of the world had never heard anything quite like it. And a lot of people hated it. It's been likened to a giant swarm of angry hornets or a herd of distraught elephants. So loud the stadium with the boozealous. It's ridiculous. It's not noisy. There's nothing irritating about it. There's nothing irritated. But at the end of it, for fans watching abroad,
呜呜祖拉持续不断的嗡嗡声并不是“美丽运动”通常听起来的样子。欧洲的足球比赛通常以支持者高唱的歌曲和口号为特色。但8万支呜呜祖拉的嗡嗡声淹没了那种人群的噪音。
the constant drone of a Vuvuzela wasn't what the beautiful game typically sounded like. European soccer games, or football games, are often characterized by songs and chants bellowed by the supporters. But the hum of 80,000 Vovazellas drowned out that type of crowd noise.
这种声音给电视转播商带来了真正的头痛。法国电视台TF1选择更换评论员的麦克风，改用那种能过滤更多背景噪音的型号。其他网络则选择使用特殊的音频过滤器，试图将呜呜祖拉的声音从他们的混音中完全消除。围绕呜呜祖拉的争议让人难以忽视。它将注意力从场上的球员身上转移开，转而聚焦在体育场的人群上。
The sound caused actual headaches for television broadcasters. French network, TF1, opted to change their commentator's microphones for a kind that would reject more background noise. Other networks chose to use special audio filters to try and eliminate the Vivazella from their sound mix altogether. The controversies surrounding the Vuvazella was hard to ignore. It drew attention away from the players on the field and placed the focus on the crowd in the
它还引发了一场关于呜呜祖拉历史及其真正起源的辩论。对于批评者来说，呜呜祖拉是一个相对较新的大规模生产的噪音制造器，但对于支持者来说，他们倾向于认为呜呜祖拉是一种乐器，一种源于南非丰富足球传统的、响亮的、引人注目的声音。1862年，在开普敦和伊丽莎白港就已经有记录在案的比赛了。这是南非足球历史学家彼得·阿莱吉。
stadiums. It also sparked a debate about the history of the Viva Zella and its true origins. For critics, the Vovazella was a role. relatively new mass-produced noise maker, but for supporters, they tended to think of the Vuvazella as an instrument, a loud, attention-grabbing sound that grew out of South Africa's rich footballing tradition. In 1862, there's already documented matches that took place in Cape Town in Port Elizabeth. That's South African football historian Peter Allegie.
那甚至是在英格兰足球协会成立之前，也是在第一套足球规则编纂之前。最初，这项运动是由英国殖民者引入的，他们试图将自己的信仰和价值观强加给当地人。但南非人很快就接受了足球，并将其变成了自己的运动。这是一个有趣的故事，殖民者的游戏被种族压迫者转化为黑人文化的支柱。
And that is a year before the Football Association was even founded in England and before the first rules of association. football were codified. Originally, the sport was introduced by British colonizers, seeking to impose their beliefs and values on the locals. But quickly, South Africans embraced football and made it their own. It's an interesting story whereby a colonial game really was transformed into a pillar of black culture by the racially oppressed.
这项运动既负担得起又容易参与，成为了黑人劳动阶级的运动。当我使用“黑人”这个词时，我指的是那些自我认同，或后来在种族隔离制度下被归类为非洲人、印度人或南亚人，以及有色人种或多种族的人。足球在种族隔离政权的官员眼中并不受重视。像板球和橄榄球这样主要由白人南非人参与的运动才得到政治支持。因此，为了帮助组织起来，足球队成立了球迷俱乐部。这些是由来自每个城市或城镇的球迷组成的规模虽小但强大的组织。球迷俱乐部会举行筹款活动，并敲定前往客场比赛的后勤安排，
The game was both affordable and accessible, becoming the sport of the world. the black working class. And when I use the term black, I'm referring to people who either are self-identified or were later classified under apartheid as African, Indian, or South Asian, and colored or multiracial. Football was not held in high regard by officials in the apartheid regime. Sports played predominantly by white South Africans like cricket and rugby were the ones that received political backing. So as a way to help organize themselves, football teams, formed supporters clubs. These were small but mighty organizations made up of fans from each city or town. Supporters clubs would hold fundraisers and hammer out travel logistics to away matches,
尤其是黑人球迷俱乐部发挥了特殊作用，让在政府中没有发言权的黑人南非人通过当地球队塑造社区的声音。成员们为球迷俱乐部的各种职位举行选举，并通过他们的正式组织，试图影响足球俱乐部的内部事务。因此，通过竞选公职来获得某种社会荣誉和知名度，在黑人社区中是非常受重视的。到了20世纪60年代，球迷俱乐部遍布南非各地，他们通过在比赛日体育场内制造的噪音让人们感受到他们的存在。人群疯狂，安静地离开去比赛，还有奇夫斯，还有大学队。
and black supporters clubs in particular played a special role, giving black South Africans who had no say in their government a voice to shape their community through the local team. Members held elections for various positions in the supporters club and also through their formal organization, they tried to influence the football club's internal affairs. And so the ability to campaign for office to achieve a kind of social honor and visibility by achieving these high offices was something that was highly valued, particularly in black communities. By the 1960s, supporter clubs existed all across South Africa, and they made their presence known to the noise they generated on game days at the stadium. Crowd of Fond Wild, just quietly left to play, and his chief to, which university too.
在球场上播放音乐、高呼、唱歌、跳舞，也许还会侮辱对手。这是一种极其令人愉悦和娱乐的事情。在此期间，种族隔离政权的政治反对派被禁止集会。这是政府试图压制解放运动的众多方式之一。但足球比赛以及随之而来的噪音和人群，使得阻止黑人政治家坐在一起变得更加困难。它在某种程度上提供了掩护，允许活动人士进行对话，甚至组织特定的颠覆性活动。这样做，在某种程度上削弱了白人国家的监视和审查。体育场是一种避难所，一个你可以变得吵闹的地方，
Playing music at the grounds, chanting, singing, dancing, maybe insulting the opponents. This was something intensely pleasurable and entertaining. During this time, political opponents of the apartheid regime were banned from gathering. It was one of the many ways the government tried to suppress the liberation movement. But football games and the noise and crowd that came with them made it harder to prevent black politicians from sitting together. It provided cover in a way by allowing activists to have conversations and even organize particular subversive activities. And in doing so, kind of undermining the white state's surveillance and censorship. The stadiums were a sort of sanctuary, a place where you could get rowdy,
对政府嗤之以鼻，在那里你可以挥舞反种族隔离运动的旗帜，同时为你最喜欢的球队加油。这也是你可以听到一位富有魅力的球迷拿起他的喇叭，发出一种很快就会传遍世界的声音的地方。所以，我自己，我是呜呜祖拉的所有者、创始人和先驱。它是由我开始的。这是弗雷迪·马凯。当我在外面走动时，他们叫我“呜呜祖拉先生”。弗雷迪实际上更喜欢被称为“萨达姆”，这是他在海湾战争期间获得的一个前卫绰号，因为他过去常在足球比赛中燃放巨大的鞭炮。人们会说这听起来像电视上的伊拉克战争。萨达姆·马凯是一个足球狂人，或者说是超级球迷，正如他们在
and thumb your nose at the government, where you could fly the flag of the anti-apartheid movement while rooting for your favorite team. It was also the place where you could hear one charismatic fan pick up his horn and make a sound that would soon be heard around the world. So myself, I'm an owner, I'm a founder, and a pioneer of the VupuZela. It is started by me. This is Freddie Makei. They call me Mr. Vububuzela when I was over. walk around. Freddy actually prefers to be called Saddam, an edgy nickname he received during the Gulf War, because he used to set off huge firecrackers at football matches. People would say it sounded like the Iraq War on TV. Saddam Marke is a soccer freak, or a superfan, as they're known in
南非所称的那样，是最热情的足球支持者。他热爱南非国家队和他来自约翰内斯堡的当地俱乐部——凯撒酋长队。在比赛中，你可以看到他戴着超大的黄色眼镜，穿着球衣，戴着被称为“马卡拉帕”的矿工头盔，上面涂着球队的颜色。对于萨达姆来说，你可以说足球就是生命。我的第一任妻子因为足球和我离婚了。我说，酋长队是我的第一任妻子。你是我的第二任妻子。每一天，每一个晚上。
South Africa, the most passionate of football supporters. He loves the South African national team and his local club, Kaiser Cheaps, from Johannesburg. He can be seen at games wearing oversized yellow glasses, a jersey, and a mining helmet known as a marker, painted in the team's colours. For Saddam, you might say football is life. My first wife divorced me because of soccer. I said, chips is my first wife. You're my second wife. Every day, every night.
当我睡觉时，我睡觉，我睡觉，酋长队，我睡觉足球，吃足球，谈论足球。我不谈论足球就无法和你交谈。在所有的足球聊天之间，我确实设法了解了萨达姆成长的过程。林波波省，和他大家庭在一起。他对呜呜祖拉的声称可以追溯到他的童年，以及他在1965年生日时收到的礼物。我的兄弟叫所罗门·马凯。他给我买了一辆自行车。
When I sleep, I sleep, I sleep, seeps, I sleep soccer, eat soccer, talk soccer. I can't talk to you without talking about soccer. In between all the soccer chat, I did manage to learn where Saddam grew up. the province of Limpopo with his large family. His claim to the Vivazella dates back to his childhood and a gift he received for his birthday in 1965. My brother called Solomon Market. He bought me a bicycle.
那辆自行车，它过去有一个喇叭。萨达姆提到的那个喇叭是自行车喇叭。那个喇叭，我在这里有。那是一个自行车喇叭。他会把那个喇叭带到当地的足球比赛中去支持他的球队。但与其挤压末端的橡胶球，他会把它取下来，对着喇叭吹。
And that bicycle, he used to have a hooter. The hootah, Saddam is referencing, is a bicycle horn. That hooter, I've gotten here. That is a bicycle hooter. He'd bring that horn to local football games to support his team. But instead of squeezing the little rubber bowl at the end, he'd take that off and blow into the horn.
我这样做是为了娱乐球员，激励他们，鼓励他们在体育场得分，用这个。1965年，当我到达约翰内斯堡时。萨达姆喜欢那个拆下来的自行车喇叭发出的声音。他称之为“阿帕拉法拉”。当他的当地足球俱乐部——凯撒酋长队在1970年成立时，萨达姆说他带了许多其他自制的喇叭去比赛。
I was doing that one to entertain the players motivate them, encourage them to score at the stadium with this one. 1965, when I arrived in John's back. Saddam liked the sound the detached bicycle horn made. He called it Apalafala. When his local football club, the Kaiser Chiefs, was established in 1970, Saddam says he brought a number of other homemade horns to the game.
这包括一个他称之为“布吉爆炸”的大型铝制喇叭。布吉爆炸基本上是一根你可以吹进去的长金属棍。它也是一根你可以用来打人的长金属棍。所以体育场最终禁止了它。但到那时，在1989年，萨达姆说他会见了一家塑料制造商，并要求他制作一个塑料版的布吉爆炸。他们创造的这种新乐器听起来很相似。但它有一个不同的名字。
This included a large aluminium horn he called a boogie blast. The boogie blast was basically a long metal stick you could blow into. It was also a long metal stick you could beat someone up with. So stadiums eventually banded. But by then in 1989, Saddam says he met with a plastics manufacturer and asked him to make a plastic version of the boogie blast. This new instrument they created sounded similar. But it had a different name.
我称它为这个，呜呜祖拉。呜呜祖拉源自祖鲁语。呜呜祖拉意味着欢迎和团结。同样的事情，呜呜祖拉，欢迎和团结。萨达姆说他在1992年创造了“呜呜祖拉”这个名字，他用他在70年代和80年代在足球比赛中吹奏他的许多喇叭，以及在90年代吹奏呜呜祖拉的照片来支持这一说法。他还录制了一张专辑，在1999年，
I call it this one, Vuvazela. Vivazela is derived from Zulu. Vuvzela mean welcome and unite. Same thing, Vuvhvhela, welcome and unite. Saddam says he coined the name Vivisela back in 1992, a claim he supports with photos of him blowing his many horns at football games in the 70s and 80s, and a Vivazella in the 90s. He also recorded an album in 1999,
名为《呜呜祖拉蜂窝》。萨达姆试图在足球比赛中出售其中一些塑料喇叭，但它从未真正流行起来。即使在凯撒酋长队的比赛中，他通常也是人群中唯一吹奏呜呜祖拉的支持者。然而，当开普敦的一家公司开始大规模生产他们自己的塑料喇叭时，这种情况开始慢慢改变，
titled Vuvuzella Cellular. Saddam tried selling some of these plastic horns at football matches, but it just never really gained traction. Even at Kaiser Chiefs games, it would often be one of the only supporters in the crowd, blowing a Vivisela. However, that slowly started to change when a company in Cape Town started mass producing their own plastic horns,
他们也称之为呜呜祖拉。公司的名字是Masen Kedahani Sports。这个名字很重要，因为公司的名字来自伊萨。这是德韦恩·杰思罗。他研究南非文化，并撰写了关于呜呜祖拉历史的文章。德韦恩说，早在2001年，尼尔·范·斯库尔克维克和他的合伙人贝维尔·巴克曼获得了资金，让他们的业务起步。
which they also called the Vuvuzela. The company's name is Masen Kedahani Sports. The clique is important because the name of the company is from Issa. This is Dwayne Jethro. He studies South African culture and wrote about the history of the Vuvazawa. Dwayne says that back in 2001, Niel van Skulkwick and his partner, Beville Buckman, got funding to get their business off the ground.
他提出了这个想法，将一个喇叭注塑成一定尺寸和规格，以便在足球比赛中轻松使用。就在这家新公司刚起步的同时，萨达姆·马凯说他联系了尼尔·范·斯库尔克维克，告诉他他是呜呜祖拉的真正发明者。萨达姆说他试图达成一笔商业交易。你和尼尔谈过吗？
He pitched this idea of injection molding a horn to a certain size and a certain specification. that would be easily used at football matches. Around the same time this new company was getting started, Saddam Make says he approached Neil Van Skulkwick to tell him that he was the true inventor of the Vuvuzela. Saddam says he tried to strike a business deal. Did you ever speak with Neil?
尼尔·范……是的，我和他谈过。他向我承诺，他向我承诺，每一个呜呜祖拉，我都会从每个呜呜祖拉中得到五个法郎。但我连一分钱都没拿到，但我并不担心。我没有抱怨。我对自己说，上帝是伟大的。我们试图追踪尼尔·范·斯库尔克维克进行采访，但没有成功。
Neil Van... Yes, I speak to him. He promised me, he promised me, each Vuvuzela, I'm going to get a five franc out of East Vuvuzela. and I never get even a scent, but I didn't worry. I didn't complain. I said to myself, God is great. We tried to track Neil Van Skulkvick down for an interview, but run successful.
根据媒体报道，他否认在2001年见过萨达姆·马凯。在采访中，范·斯库尔克维克并没有声称自己是呜呜祖拉的发明者，但他和他的公司断言他们确实推广了它。他们的喇叭版本更便宜、更安全，因为你不能用它打人。其实，罗曼，从技术上讲，你还是可以用它打人的。对。它不会那么疼。好吧，你看，你知道，我们处于开发第一款塑料版细长喇叭的最前沿，这种喇叭过去在南非的足球比赛中使用。而且因为，你知道，那些喇叭在当时很不安全，我们看到了这个缺口。
According to media reports, he denied ever meeting with Saddam Markeh in 2001. In interviews, Van Skulkvick didn't claim to be the inventor of the Vibuzela, but he and his company assert that they did popularize it. their version of the horn was cheaper and safer in that you couldn't beat someone up with one. Actually, Roman, you technically could beat someone up with it. Right. It wouldn't hurt as bad. Well, look, you know, we were at the forefront of developing the first plastic version of a thin horn that used to be used in, you know, football here in South Africa. And because, you know, those horns were quite unsafe at the time, we saw the gap in the moment.
去生产那个版本的塑料版。最初，范·斯库尔克维克的公司也难以销售他们的呜呜祖拉，但当他们开始专注于营销时，情况发生了变化。该公司在足球比赛中免费分发呜呜祖拉，并与一些当地俱乐部合作，让更多的呜呜祖拉进入南非的体育场。没过多久，人们对呜呜祖拉的兴趣就增加了，销量也开始增长。很快，这种乐器就可以在全国各地的比赛中清晰地听到。
to produce a plastic version of that one. Initially, Van Sculkvick's company also struggled to sell their Vuvazella's, but that changed when they started to focus on the marketing. The company handed out Viverzellas for free at football matches and partnered with some local clubs to get more of them into South Africa stadiums. It wasn't long before there was more interest in the Vivisela, and sales started to grow. Soon, the instrument could be distinctly heard at games across the country.
是的，非常感谢，罗伯。下半场即将开始，斯坦顿·弗雷德里克斯换下何塞·马卡莫。这就是酋长队做出的改变。呜呜祖拉实际上是一种通用喇叭，这意味着范·斯库尔克维克无法为该设计申请专利。但“呜呜祖拉”这个词是独一无二的，所以他的公司为这个名字注册了商标。随着南非准备申办2010年世界杯，
Yeah, thanks very much, Rob. The second half about to get underway, Stanton Fredericks on for Josemakamo. So that's the change the chiefs have made. The Vuvuzela, effectively being a generic horn, meant that Van Skulkevick wasn't able to patent the design. But the word Vubuzella was unique, so his company got a trademark for the name. And as South Africa prepared their bid to host the 2010 World Cup,
范·斯库尔克维克和他的公司准备利用这次活动。该公司的努力旨在将呜呜祖拉定位为——包括其官方口号——“南非的原始声音”。他们认识到，让重要的南非足球官员，以及试图在当地和国际上为南非申办争取支持的政治家手中拥有呜呜祖拉，是一个营销机会。所以你看到的是像在当地舞台上赠送呜呜祖拉作为外交礼物之类的事情。政治家们被递上了呜呜祖拉等等。当国际足联宣布南非赢得主办权时，
Van Skolkvick and his company were ready to capitalize on the event. The company's efforts were designed to position the Vivisela as, including its official slogan, the original sound of South Africa. They recognized that there was a marketing opportunity in having the Vuvuzela in the hands of important South African footballing officials, but also politicians that were trying to drum up support both locally and internationally for South Africa's bid. So what you saw was things like the gifting of Vuvuzela as diplomatic gifts on local stages. politicians were handed, vovozellas, etc. When FIFA announced South Africa's winning bid to host the tournament,
欢乐的庆祝活动中包括了这些塑料呜呜祖拉。激进的营销奏效了。在世界杯前夕，南非足球的声音与呜呜祖拉紧密相连。这种乐器甚至出现在全国性的营销活动中，由著名的橄榄球运动员带头，他们被召集来推广2009年联合会杯，这是一种世界杯的测试赛。
the joyful celebrations included these plastic vivuzillas. The aggressive marketing worked. In the lead-up to the World Cup, the sound of South African football was inextricably linked to the Vuvazella. The instrument even appeared in national marketing campaigns, fronted by prominent rugby players who'd been called in to promote the 2009 Confederation's Cup, a sort of test-run tournament for the World Cup.
我们支持国际足联联合会杯。联合会杯是全球电视观众第一次接触到呜呜祖拉。第一场比赛后不久，国际辩论就开始了。我发现的一件事，我不知道我是不是唯一一个，我发现极其痛苦的是，这种持续不断的嗡嗡声。他们吹着这些看起来像小号的东西。不知道他们的肺里怎么有足够的空气。而且它永无止境。
We behind the FIFA Confederations Cup. The Confederations Cup was the first time a global TV audience had been exposed to the Vivazala. Not long after the first game, the international debate started taking off. One thing that I found, I don't know if I'm the only person, I found excruciating, was this constant droning that is going on. They're blowing these like trumpet-looking. know how they have enough air in their lungs. And it never ends.
这简直是，就像你连续90分钟被一群蝗虫攻击一样。我完全知道你在说什么。他们怎么能一直那样做？我不知道。我不知道他们是否轮流。媒体报道很快就对呜呜祖拉对世界杯的潜在影响提出了担忧。
And it is just a, it is like you are being attacked by a swarm of locusts for 90 consecutive minutes. I know exactly what you're talking about. How can they constantly do that? I don't know. I don't know if they take turns. Media reports were quick to raise concerns about the Vuvuzella's potential impact on the World Cup.
塞普·布拉特，那位深受爱戴且完全没有争议的国际足联主席，被问及呜呜祖拉是否会在即将到来的世界杯上被禁止。令许多人惊讶的是，他站出来支持这种乐器，称这是“非洲文化”。我们在非洲，我们必须允许他们尽可能多地实践他们的文化。他又是记者马克·格里森。那一刻让我印象深刻，那是转折点，
Set Blatter, the beloved and totally non-controversial FIFA president, was asked if the Vivisela that was going to be banned at the upcoming World Cup. To the surprise of many, he came out in support of the instrument, saying it is African culture. We are in Africa, and we have to allow them to practice their culture as much as they want to. He's journalist Mark Gleason again. It struck me at that point that that was the turning moment,
因为我确实认为呜呜祖拉是否会成为2010年世界杯的一部分对国际足联来说是一个问题。这是一个我记得非常清楚的时刻，我心想，这就是现在的呜呜祖拉。我们将在2010年拥有呜呜祖拉。从世界杯开球的那一刻起，呜呜祖拉就是一个持续且顽固的存在。从体育场的气氛
because I do think it was a bit of an issue for FIFA, whether the Vuvuzila was going to be part of the 2010 World Cup or not. It's a moment I remember very distinctly, and thinking to myself, this is the Vuvuzella now. We will have the Vuvuzela in 2010. From the moment the World Cup kicked off, the Vuvuzela was a constant and persistent presence. From the atmosphere in the stadiums
到深夜电视节目上的笑话，它无处不在。虽然广播公司试图在他们那边减轻噪音，但DIY解决方案正在互联网上传播。其中之一包括通过你的电脑处理电视音频，并使用软件去除呜呜祖拉的特定频率。随着锦标赛的继续，场上的球员指责呜呜祖拉造成了沟通问题。莱昂内尔·梅西，被许多人认为是世界上最好的球员，甚至把噪音归咎于他的球队丢球。这些抱怨甚至足以激发南非医学杂志的一项研究。
to the jokes on late-night TV, it was inescapable. While broadcasters were trying to mitigate the noise on their end, DIY solutions were making their way around the internet. One of them involved writing your TV's audio through your computer and using software to remove the particular frequencies of the Vuvazella. And as the tournament continued, players on the field cited the Vivuzella for causing communication problems. Leonel Messey, regarded by many as the best player in the world, even went so far as to blame the noise for his team conceding a goal. The complaints were even enough to inspire a study from the South African Medical Journal.
它测量了呜呜祖拉的声级，峰值达到131分贝。这和手提钻或喷气发动机一样响。结论是，长期或经常接触可能会导致噪音引起的听力损失。呜呜祖拉没有中间地带。你要么爱它，要么恨它。大多数对呜呜祖拉的愤怒来自一种非常欧洲中心主义的视角。这是一个关于什么被认为是足球球迷文化中适当的争论，
It measured the Vivisela's sound levels, which peaked at 131 decibels. That's as loud as a jackhammer or a jet engine. It concluded that prolonged or regular exposure could cause noise. induced hearing loss. There was no middle ground with the Vuvazala. You either loved it or hated it. Most of the Vivazala outrage came from a very Eurocentric perspective. It was an argument about what was considered appropriate in football fan culture,
德韦恩·杰思罗说，这是对“非洲性”概念的攻击。它提出了这些古老的、关于非洲作为黑暗大陆的观念，来自非洲的文化形式被认为是原始的或过时的等等。我认为这就是这种愤怒在南非被接收的方式。正是在那个空间里，不仅是南非足球协会，而且南非球迷也开始反击并大声疾呼，说这就是我们在体育传统和体育球迷文化中代表自己的方式。
which Dwayne Jethro says was an attack on the idea of Africanness. It raises these old, old ideas of Africa as a dark continent, cultural forms from Africa as being primitive or outdated, etc. And I think that's how the outrage was received in South Africa. And it was in that space that not only the South African Football Association, but also South African fans started to speak back and speak out and to say that this is how we represent ourselves in our sporting traditions and sporting fan culture.
虽然呜呜祖拉受到国际观众的谴责，但同样真实的是，许多南非的游客也接受了它。对于喜剧演员特雷弗·诺亚和许多其他南非人来说，这种挪用才是问题所在。在南非，我们应该有一个规定，你必须有执照才能吹呜呜祖拉。你不能就这样来到这里，不知道呜呜祖拉的礼仪，随意吹奏。英国球迷，西班牙球迷，中午，他们就在那里，早上9点。你在做什么？这太有趣了。
While the Vivizawa was condemned by international audiences, it's also true that many visitors to South Africa embraced it. For comedian Trevor Noah and plenty of other South Africans, the appropriation was the problem. In South Africa, we should have a thing where you have to have a license to blow Vuvuzela. You can't just come here, not knowing Vuvuzela etiquette, blowing it randomly. The English fans, the Spanish fans, middle of the day, there they are, 9 a.m. What are you doing? It's so much fun.
这是错的。这是错误的人。你知道谁应该吹呜呜祖拉吗？合格的、熟练的从业者？酋长队和海盗队的支持者。那才是应该吹呜呜祖拉的人。毫无疑问，对于成千上万的南非人来说，呜呜祖拉是民族认同的表达。但作为第一个主办世界杯的非洲国家，这种乐器代表的不仅仅是南非。对于世界各地的观众来说，它代表了整个非洲大陆的声音。
It's wrong. It's the wrong people. You know who should be blowing Vufuselah's qualified, skilled practitioners? Chiefs and pirate supporters. That's who should be blowing Vuvuzela's. There is no doubt that for thousands of South Africans, the Vuvuzella was an expression of national identity. But as the first African nation to host the World Cup, the instrument came to represent more than just South Africa. For viewers watching around the world, it represented the sound of an entire continent.
这是有意为之的。国际足联和南非组委会将锦标赛营销为“非洲的世界杯”。口号是“庆祝非洲的人性”。即使是锦标赛的官方歌曲，你肯定记得，也宣称“现在是属于非洲的时刻”。而且因为呜呜祖拉成为了赛事的一个巨大焦点，彼得·拉莱吉说这种乐器也被包裹在锦标赛的所有肖像学中。政府热衷于使用它，因为它将其视为一种“非洲性”的象征，
And that was by design. FIFA and South Africa's organizing committee marketed the tournament as Africa's World Cup. The slogan was Celebrate Africa's Humanity. Even the official song of the tournament, which you'll surely remember, proclaims this time is for Africa. And because the Vivazela became such a huge focal point of the event, Peter Raleji says the instrument got wrapped up in all the archonography of the tournament too. The government was keen on using it because it saw it as a symbol of, you know, Africanness.
但也有其他讨厌它的非洲游客说，你知道，我来自的地方没有吹喇叭的传统。那么这怎么能代表泛非主义呢？锦标赛的迪士尼化让呜呜祖拉感觉很廉价，就像它周围的其他营销一样。随着这种廉价感而来的是对它真实性的一定怀疑。尽管这种乐器受到如此多的批评，但人们仍然想为它的存在争取功劳。
but there were also other African visitors who hated it who said, you know, we have no tradition of horn blowing where I come from. So how is this supposed to represent pan-Africanism? The Disneyfication of the tournament made the Vivazella feel cheap, like the rest of the marketing around it. And with that cheapness came a certain skepticism about its authenticity. Despite the instrument being so criticized, people still wanted to claim credit for its existence.
关于它的历史和起源的争议与锦标赛并存。媒体报道的一个故事将呜呜祖拉与库杜羚羊的角联系起来。历史上，动物角在南非文化中一直被使用，但将库杜角与呜呜祖拉联系起来的理论很可能是受到马梅洛迪日落队的一位支持者的启发，他以带角去足球比赛而闻名。他的研究员又是德韦恩·杰思罗。
The disputes over its history, and origin played out side by side with the tournament. One story the press picked up connected the Viverzella to the horn of the kudu, a species of antelope. Historically, animal horns have been used in South African culture, but the theory linking the kudu horn to the Viva Zella was likely inspired by one supporter of the team Mamelode sundowns, who was known to bring the horn to football games. His researcher Dwayne Jethro again.
虽然我们在南非确实有本土的吹角传统是绝对真实的，但我们是否以及如何能将呜呜祖拉的谱系一直追溯到那些本土传统，这是可以争论和辩论的。另一个说法来自拿撒勒浸信会，也被称为谢姆贝，他们有自己的角。谢姆贝教会在夸祖鲁-纳塔尔地区运作。他们每年都有朝圣活动，而在这次年度朝圣活动中，他们使用一种叫做“伊齐博穆”的角。
While it is absolutely true that we have indigenous traditions of horn blowing in South Africa, whether and how we can trace the genealogy of the Vuvuzela all the way back to those indigenous traditions, that's open to argument and debate. Another claim came from the Nazareth Baptist Church, also known as the Shembe, who have a horn of their own. The Shembe Church operates in the Kuzulu-Natal area. They have an annual pilgrimage And during this annual pilgrimage They use a horn called the Izibomu
当足球迷吹奏呜呜祖拉时，他们觉得他们的角所产生的圣灵在足球氛围的这种背景下被挪用了。谢姆贝教会首先指责萨达姆·马凯挪用了伊齐博穆。他们说他在90年代访问了教会，并在不允许将金属角带入体育场时，用塑料制作了自己的版本。萨达姆否认了这些指控。
When football fans were blowing the Vufuzele, they felt that the Holy Spirit that was generated by their horn Had been appropriated in this context of football atmosphere The Shembe first accused Saddam Markei of appropriating the Isambomu They said he visited the church in the 90s And fashioned his own version in plastic when he wasn't allowed to bring the metal horn into stadiums. Saddam denies these accusations.
教会最初威胁要对国际足联和世界杯组织者采取法律行动，然后才针对尼尔·范·斯库尔克维克和他的公司。根据当时的媒体报道，双方最终达成了和解。所有关于呜呜祖拉起源的说法都有其独特之处，但正是世界杯锦标赛的高调背景提高了所有权辩论的赌注。
The church threatened the legal action initially against FIFA and World Cup organizers before going after Neil Van Skulkwick and his company. According to media reports at the time, the two parties eventually came to a settlement. All these claims regarding the origin of the Vufuzella are compelling in their own way, but it was the heightened context of the World Cup tournament that raised the stakes in the ownership debate.
在所有文化遗产辩论中，起源和所有权是能够声称某种遗产传统的非常重要的要素和主线。在你能够声称所有权和有效的、有说服力的起源故事之前，你不能声称一种遗产传统。尽管缺乏直接的起源故事，但呜呜祖拉仍然被认为是文化遗产，至少在一些机构眼中是这样。英国国家足球博物馆和大英博物馆的藏品中都有呜呜祖拉。所以如果我们使用这些遗产机构的收藏原则
In all cultural heritage debates, origins and ownership are really important elements and strands of being able to claim a certain heritage tradition. You cannot claim a heritage tradition until you can claim ownership and a valid persuasive origin story. Despite the lack of a straightforward origin story, the Vivazoa is still considered cultural heritage, at least in the eyes of some institutions. The United Kingdom's National Football Museum and the British Museum both have vivisela's in their collections. So if we use the collecting principles of these heritage institutions
作为遗产如何被界定和制造的指导方针，那么你就会看到呜呜祖拉进入了那个遗产叙事。我的意思是，大英博物馆对窃取文化文物的功劳并不陌生。但如果你在他们的网站上查找呜呜祖拉的列表，他们只认可一个起源故事。对我来说，谈论这个，呜呜祖拉，你让我的一天变得美好。他们将发明归功于弗雷迪·萨达姆·马凯。你让我的梦想成真了。
as a guideline for how heritage is staked and made, then you see the vovozella entering into that heritage narrative. I mean, the British Museum is no stranger to stealing credit for cultural artefacts. But if you look up the Viverzella's listing on their website, there is only one origin story they recognize. For me, to talk about this, Vubesela, you make my day. They attribute the invention to none other than Freddie Saddam Marke. You make my dream come true.
我感到很感激，因为呜呜祖拉是我的宝贝。萨达姆的故事是呜呜祖拉最接近实际起源故事的东西。而且与2010年围绕呜呜祖拉的噪音不同，他的故事核心很简单。他热爱他的球队，他想尽可能大声地表达对他们的支持。今天，呜呜祖拉不像2010年那样突出了。南非世界杯结束后几年，国际足联转而禁止它们参加所有重大锦标赛。其他几个主要体育联盟也一样。
I'm feeling grateful because Mubuzela is my baby. Saddam's story is the closest thing the Viverzella has to an actual origin story. And unlike the noise that surrounded the Viverzella in 2010, his story at its core is simple. He loved his team and he wanted to show his support for them as loud as possible. Today, Voo-Zellos aren't nearly as prominent as they were back in 2010. A few years after the South African World Cup ended, FIFA turned around and banned them from all major tournaments. And several other major sports leagues have as well.
但对于德韦恩·杰思罗来说，这伴随着一线希望。我很高兴没有未来的世界杯锦标赛会受到呜呜祖拉美妙声音的祝福，这种声音将永远保持南非特色。就在几个月前，南非女子足球队赢得了她们有史以来第一个非洲国家杯。当球队到达机场时，她们受到了表达民族自豪感的球迷的欢迎，
But for Dwayne Jethro, that comes with this overlining. I'm very glad that no future World Cup tournament. will be blessed with a beautiful sound of the Vubuzela, that the sound will always remain South African. Just a few months ago, the South African women's football team won their first ever Africa Cup of Nations. When the team arrived at the airport, they were greeted by fans expressing their national pride
通过歌曲和口号。萨达姆·马凯也在那里，吹着他的呜呜祖拉。没有人抱怨噪音。球迷们只是以他们想要庆祝的方式庆祝。他们想要庆祝的方式。所以我又和詹姆斯·帕金森在一起了，你还有另一个关于南非足球文化的故事要告诉我们。
through songs and chants. Saddam Markei was there too, blowing his Viva Zala. There were no complaints about the noise. The fans just celebrated the way they wanted to celebrate. the way they wanted to celebrate. So I'm back with James Parkinson, and you've got another story about football culture in South Africa for us.
是的。所以当我在做这个故事时，出现了一些其他有趣的细节，这与体育场内的噪音制造文化有关。我现在给你发一张照片，这样你就能看到我在说什么了。所以这一定是萨达姆·马凯，我们在片中听到了他的声音，他有一个非常棒的声音，还有一个非常棒的外表。
Yes. So a few other interesting details came up while I was working on this story, and it has to do with that culture of noise-making in the stadiums. And I'm dropping you a picture now, so you can see what I'm talking about. So this must be Saddam Makeh, who we heard from him in the piece, who has a really great voice and a really great look to go with it.
是的，这就是呜呜祖拉名声的萨达姆。在这张照片里，他全副武装，在足球比赛中声嘶力竭地尖叫。他戴着非常大、滑稽的黄色眼镜，戴着一个贴着各种不同标志的头盔，上面有凯撒酋长队甚至奥兰多海盗队的冰冷贴纸。是的。所以我想谈谈那个头盔，马卡拉帕，因为那是另一件像呜呜祖拉一样在世界杯期间流行起来的物品。所以“马卡拉帕”这个词实际上意味着“刮板”。而“刮板”是指那些过去搬到约翰内斯堡等城市在矿井工作的外籍劳工。人们会说他们靠刮东西为生。所以故事是这样的，
Yes, this is Saddam, Vivizella fame. And in this picture, he's decked out and all this gear screaming his lungs out at a football match. He's wearing really large, comically yellow glasses and a helmet with all these different logos on it and icy stickers of Kaiser Chiefs and even Orlando Pirates on it. Yes. So what I want to talk about is that helmet, the Macarapa, because that was another item like the Viverzella that gained popularity during the World Cup. So the word Macarapa actually means scrapers. And scrapers is a reference to the migrant workers. He used to move into cities like Johannesburg to work in the mines. People would say they scrape for a living. And so the story goes
一个凯撒酋长队的球迷，这次不是萨达姆，在70年代去了一场特别吵闹的比赛，他看到有人被瓶子砸中了头。所以很自然地，在下一场比赛中，他想，你知道，我只是……他当时想，好吧，我应该戴那个头盔。是的，完全正确。所有这些人都在戴头盔。我应该戴头盔。是的。所以这个球迷开始用球队的颜色粉刷这些头盔并在比赛中出售，它就成了一件事。但这并不是南非矿井与体育场内制造噪音之间的唯一联系。德韦恩·杰思罗告诉我，还有这种声音。这是一种警报。这是一种发条警报。它发出……像旧的空袭警报。
that a Carter Chiefs fan, not Saddam this time, went to a particularly rowdy game back in the 70s where he saw someone get hit in the head with a bottle. So naturally for the next game, he thought, you know, I just... He was like, well, I should wear that helmet. Yeah, exactly. All these people were wearing helmets. I should wear a helmet. Yeah. So this fan started painting these helmets in the team's colors and selling them at games, and it became a thing. But this isn't the only connection between the minds of South Africa and noise making in the stadiums. Duane Jethro told me there's also this sound. It's a kind of alarm. It's a wind-up alarm. It goes... Like an old aerate siren.
完全正确，是的。这些警报过去有这种非常具体的用途。这是矿工在工作中换班时会听到的声音。所以球迷们会，你知道，带这些手持警报器在比赛中制造噪音，它们在90年代非常流行。是的。因为这些是工人阶级的球迷，所以他们带着他们身上有的东西。他们带着他们的头盔。他们带着他们在日常生活中使用的警报器。是的，他们拿起他们的头盔，你知道，这些警报器，并以某种方式重新利用它们，以反映他们作为矿工在南非足球文化中的生活。哦，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。
Exactly, yeah. And these alarms used to have this very specific use. It was the sound miners would hear for their shift change at work. So fans would, you know, bring these handheld sirens to make noise at the games, and they were pretty popular in the Nannis. Yeah. Because these are working class fans, so they're bringing what they have on them. They're bringing their helmets. They're bringing their sirens that they use in everyday life. Yeah, they're picking up their helmets and, you know, these alarms and sort of repurposing them to reflect their lives as miners in the culture of South African football. Oh, I love that. I love that.
是的，我最喜欢的例子之一是他们重新利用了他们在矿井里唱的工作歌曲，球迷们随后会在比赛中大声唱出来。它叫《Shoshaloza》。你唱它，它大概是这样的，Shosholoza，我不知道歌词是否正确，但这就是滚动节奏的走向。这是一种你唱的歌，
Yeah, and one of my favorite examples of this is that they repurposed a work song they would sing in the minds, that fans would then sing, you know, loudly at games. It's called Shoshaloza. And you sing it, it goes something like, Shosholoza, I don't know the words properly, but that's how the rolling beat goes. It's the kind of song that you sing
当你真的想激起人群时，南非各地的南非人都知道这首歌。它讲述了移民从南部非洲的不同地区搬来在矿井工作的故事。所以《Shoshaloza》，这首传统的矿工歌曲，实际上在90年代变得非常流行。人们称它为南非的第二国歌。它由工人们以呼应的方式演唱，以某种方式，你知道，产生节奏，也为了缓解在地下长时间艰苦工作带来的压力。
when you really want to rouse up the crowd and South Africans across the board know the song. And it speaks to migrants, moving from different parts of Southern Africa to come and work on the mines. So Shoshal Lohza, this traditional minor song, actually became quite popular in the 90s. People refer to it as South Africa's second national anthem. It was sung in a call-and-response style by the workers to kind of, you know, generate a rhythm and also to alleviate stress from working long, hard days underground.
《Shoshaloza》意味着“前进”或“为下一个人开路”。著名的是，纳尔逊·曼德拉谈到了他在开普敦海岸外的罗本岛被监禁时，是如何与许多其他政治犯一起唱这首歌的，以及这首歌如何反映了种族隔离期间的斗争。我的意思是，这让我想起了你在片中提到的，这些比赛和围绕它们的噪音，我的意思是，是的，这是关于体育、游戏、休闲和乐趣，
Shoshal-Laza means go forward or make the way for the next man. And famously, Nelson Mandela spoke about how he would sing this song while he would sing this song while he was imprisoned on Robin Island off the coast of Cape Town, along with many other political prisoners, and the ways in which the song reflected the struggle during apartheid. I mean, it reminds me of something that you mentioned in the piece that these games and the noise that surrounds them, I mean, yes, it's about sports and a game and about leisure and fun,
Shoshal-Laza的意思是勇往直前或为后来者开辟道路。众所周知，纳尔逊·曼德拉曾谈到他在开普敦海岸外的罗本岛监狱服刑时，是如何与其他许多政治犯一起唱这首歌的，这首歌反映了种族隔离时期的斗争。我的意思是，这让我想起了你在文章中提到的，这些比赛以及围绕它们的喧嚣，是的，这关乎体育、游戏、休闲和娱乐，
but it's also like a certain amount of political resistance just built into the fact that there's people singing along loudly in a stadium, they're playing instruments, And there's this way to make noise for your team, but also, you know, let the powers of be know that, you know, we're all here. And there's a bunch of us and we're all here. Yeah, we're here. And, you know, we're really loud.
但这本身也带有一种政治抵抗的意味，因为人们在体育场里大声合唱、演奏乐器，这不仅是为自己的球队呐喊助威，也是在向当权者传达一个信号：我们都在这里，我们人多势众，而且我们声音响亮。
And we're going to let you know. Well, thank you again, James. I mean, this was such a cool, fascinating history. And I'm so glad that you shared it with us. Thanks, Norman. Anytime. That story originally aired in 2022. It was produced by James Parkinson and edited by Jason DeLeon.
我们要让你们知道。好的，再次感谢你，詹姆斯。这段历史真是太酷、太迷人了，很高兴你能与我们分享。谢谢你，诺曼。随时欢迎。该报道最初于2022年播出，由詹姆斯·帕金森制作，杰森·德莱昂编辑。
Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. with additional music provided by Freddie Saddam Makeh. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Don, Vivian Lay,
混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐由斯旺·里尔创作，弗雷迪·萨达姆·马凯提供了额外音乐。事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙负责。凯西·2是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·唐、薇薇安·莱，
Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, Talon and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building. in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server.
乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%不可见》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大厦，坐落在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的Discord服务器上找到我们。
There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在99PI.org网站上有相关链接，以及《99%不可见》的所有往期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。